derrière les murs de ce théâtre la
soirée de gala a failli basculer dans
l'horreur le concours de Miss Belgique
était visé par un attentat terroriste
quelques heures avant la cérémonie la
police est informée d'une menace elle
interpelle un homme de 46 ans à bord de
son véhicule plusieurs armes et un gilet
par balle la salle où se déroule le
concours est évacué dans l'urgence
l'individu a été inculpé pour tentative
d'attentat terroriste mais à ce stade la
justice reste encore très floue sur ses
motivations c'est quelqu'un qui de
nationalité belge qui n'est jamais
apparue dans les radars l'homme a été
placé en détention son avocat réfute
l'effet qui lui sont reprochés alors
merci Gaëtan d'être avec nous Gaëtan
c'est une histoire incroyable que vous
allez nous raconter ce soir on va revoir
on a l'image du lancement de l'émission
parce que c'est vous qui animiez Miss
Belgique ouais je sais que vous êtes
encore un peu débout sur les il y a eu
quelques jours compliqué on va dire
depuis samedi soir voilà ça c'est un peu
bousculé un peu partout alors on va
regarder l'image de
bonsoir bonsoir tout le monde
j'espère que vous allez bien j'espère
que vous êtes bien installé et on tenait
déjà à s'excuser auprès de nos chers
spectateurs qui sont chez eux à la
maison pour ce retard d'une heure 10
presse malheureusement on a eu affaire à
des soupçons terroristes ici au sein de
Miss Belgique et au sein de la salle
tout est maintenant sous contrôle je
tenais déjà à remercier toutes les
équipes de police qui qui était avec
nous donc soyez indulgent on va faire le
show must go one alors vous allez nous
raconter ce qui était c'est passé vous
étiez en train de préparer le chaud
quand tout à coup vous découvrez une
centaine de policiers dans le théâtre
ouais en fait j'arrive j'arrive dans la
salle pour aller chercher un ami et là
je remarque beaucoup de policiers et pas
des policiers locaux c'est des policiers
fédéraux comme on dit chez nous donc ils
ont d'autres insignes donc on sait que
c'est grave qu'il y a quelque chose qui
se passe d'accord donc là je m'interroge
et donc je sors directement je vais voir
directement le comité qui est au courant
de ce qui se passe et je demande au
Comité Miss Belgique que s'est-il c'est
pourquoi il y a autant de policiers et
donc là on me dit ben écoute il y a une
alerte elle est bombe il faut évacuer
toute la salle qu'à partir de ce
moment-là on évacue
ça a été compliqué on est vaincu je me
retrouve avec ma collègue dehors
avec Virginie qui est ma présentatrice
on se retrouve dehors et et là on
panique on commence à paniquer parce que
là on nous dit alerte à la bombe on est
dehors derrière le bâtiment derrière les
coulisses et on se dit qu'est-ce qu'on
fait donc on attend dans le froid avec
le costume avec la robe on avait rien
sur nous on a tendance le froid et
à partir de ce moment-là ben les
questions fusent dans ma tête je me dis
ce qui va se passer et puis les infos
commencent à tomber au compte-goutte la
salle a été évacuée il y a une toute
autre ambiance entre les coulisses et
l'intérieur de de la salle et
l'extérieur le public n'a pas ressenti
ce stress la police a super bien fait
son boulot le comité a super bien fait
son travail ça s'est passé sans panique
ça a été cool vous savez en Belgique on
n'est pas des grands stressés donc donc
ça c'est plutôt bien passé par contre en
coulisses on recevait les les
informations au compte-goutte et là ça a
été stressant en fait vous êtes donc
comme vous l'avez dit évacué de la salle
vous attendez dehors et un homme a été
arrêté près du théâtre avec plusieurs
armes sans sa possession c'est surtout
ça qui est important aussi la police
l'avait repéré à cause de messages dans
le contenu qui est laissé penser à une
attaque terroriste ouais et on apprend
ça effectivement et donc là c'est encore
plus la panique parce que est-ce qu'il
est tout seul et ce qui a plusieurs
personnes on ne le sait pas j'ai le
commissaire qui vient me voir avant le
show j'ai le maire de la ville qui vient
me voir et qui me dit écoutez qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce que est-ce que vous
voulez monter sur scène malgré tout j'ai
déjà est-ce qu'on a limité les risques
effectivement toutes les entrées sont
barricadées la police est partout donc
tout ça ok mais est-ce qu'on fait le
show c'est à dire est-ce qu'on prend le
risque donc je demande aux responsables
je demande est-ce que vous êtes sûr
qu'il est tout seul et ce qui a pas un
commando est-ce qu'il y a pas d'autres
personnes qui sont appliquées l'enquête
est en cours alors cet homme cet hiver
17h30 un homme d'une quarantaine
d'années était interpellé près du
théâtre en possession de plusieurs armes
suite à l'envoi de plusieurs messages
donc sans penser à une future attaque
terroriste cet homme a été ensuite
inculpé pour tentative d'assassinat
terroriste puis écroué ce dimanche
l'homme était auditionné il annoncé il
annoncé vouloir faire exploser le
théâtre ouais mais il avait il avait un
arsenal il avait même du gaz chimique je
sais pas à quoi ça lui aurait servi mais
en tout cas il avait un vrai Arsenal
donc donc en fait on m'a prévenu le
commissaire m'a dit 5 minutes si on
n'était pas arrivé dans les 5 minutes
vous étiez dedans non ah ouais parce
qu'il était déterminé en fait le gastru
le gars était sur le parking il se
dirigeait vers la salle il était
déterminé donc
à partir de ce moment là
c'est très très compliqué en fait de se
retrouver sur sur le plateau et de voir
faire son métier d'animateur vous le
savez je pense que tout le monde ici le
fait par passion avant tout
moi je suis un amoureux de mon maquette
c'est gratuit
non mais je suis un amoureux de mon
métier j'adore ça je fais ça depuis
l'âge de 13 ans je me vois pas faire
autre chose et je me suis posé une
question avec ma coprées qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on monte est-ce que si
même il y a 5 % de chances qui est une
autre personne qui rentre dans la salle
et qui fasse le truc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors il y a une phrase qui m'est
passé par par la par la tête je me suis
dit quitte à mourir autant mourir avec
moitié mourir sur scène je me suis dit
je m'en fous il y a 5% de chance on est
en sécurité mais il y a quand même ce
petit cette petite peur et donc je monte
sur le plateau on le fait
mais je le fais voilà il faut garder le
sourire il faut rien montrer à l'antenne
je me suis excusé auprès des
téléspectateurs mais il faut garder
cette phase
si si au début j'ai dit effectivement
qu'il y avait eu des menaces etc mais on
en a pas fait tout un plat et là en fait
j'ai un terrorié intériorisé toute cette
peur et en fait quand je suis sorti du
plateau après toutes ces élections j'ai
voulu faire une vidéo pour m'excuser
auprès des spectateurs parce qu'il y a
eu des bugs il y a des techniciens qui
sont partis de peur je peux pas leur en
vouloir merci à eux d'ailleurs mais ils
sont partis ils sont rentrés à la maison
je me suis retrouvé sans personne dans
l'oreillette donc j'ai tout fait Alain
pro un peu comme moi
et donc j'étais en colère et j'avais
envie juste de dire voilà de dire ce que
je pensais au téléspectateurs mais
là j'ai prononcé les gars j'ai eu peur
quand j'ai prononcé ce mot là pendant la
cérémonie vous aviez toujours
vous avez peur qu'on vous c'est assez
rémunier vous êtes dit il peut se passer
un truc je regardais vous avez le
plateau en face de moi il y avait des
entrées un peu partout mon regard était
porté vers ses entrées tout le temps ah
ouais tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps parce que et puis je voulais
faire cette cérémonie parce que les
nanas là elle travaille depuis des mois
c'est un rêve de princesse c'est un rêve
de petite fille moi c'était mon rêve
d'être animateur elle c'est le rêve de
passer dans une élection de Miss je me
suis dit comment moi je peux dire
écoutez les gars moi je monte pas sur
scène j'ai trop peur tant pis je rentre
chez moi c'est impossible c'est
impossible je devais le faire pour ces
nanas pour pour l'équipe technique pour
tous ceux qui ont bossé on a bossé trois
jours à répéter je pouvais pas lâcher
tout le monde avec ma collègue alors il
y a comme vous dites il y a des gens qui
sont c'est le plateau qui ont dit non on
fait pas l'émission dans ces conditions
quoi plusieurs techniciens se sont dit
ouais nous on a on a trop peur notamment
la personne qui devait me parler dans
oreillette qui me donnait des tops etc
elle est partie le Real s'est retrouvé à
faire la réalisation lui-même
différentes caméras les différentes
parties techniques le son les caméras
tout seul donc effectivement il ne
pouvait pas gérer l'oreillette en même
temps donc il comptait sur moi et sur le
régisseur plateau et sur mes fiches pour
pour que je puisse avancer il y a eu
beaucoup de changements on a dû couper
les séquences parce que fatalement on a
repris on a pris une heure une heure dix
de retard donc on n'avait pas non plus
toute la nuit on pouvait pas prolonger
toute la nuit donc j'ai dû me réadapter
etc depuis deux jours vous me dites les
journées sont difficiles ben ouais les
journées sont difficiles surtout j'ai
pas dormi de samedi à dimanche parce que
ça travaille le samedi à 8h30 vous avez
tous les journalistes qui vous appellent
toutes les télévisions pour savoir un
peu ce qui s'est passé donc là vous
dormez pas parce que vous êtes en plein
d'adrénaline encore en fait vous vous
revivez le truc non-stop sans cesse sans
cesse et puis à un moment donné voilà je
me retrouve ici j'aurais vraiment aimé
être là et vous rencontrez et venir
déconner et faire le point mais pas dans
ces circonstances là c'est c'est voilà
Gilles et plus les heures passent plus
les forces de police sont persuadés
d'avoir éviter un bain de sang il faut
savoir que le média belge muse blague a
révélé que l'homme avait écrit à son
ex-femme des mails en disant je vais
commettre un bain de sang donc
visiblement il avait préparé avec un
armement lourd un gilet par balle dans
la voiture effectivement du gaz ce qui
semble être un attentat de masse à
l'intérieur de la salle il avait il
avait 90 balles sur lui 90 balles avec
cinq chargeurs
90 balles 90
Castaldi c'est vrai que ça a dit en
direct après bah moi je m'étonne qu'en
fait ils aient maintenu la soirée
je pense que la bonne décision ça aurait
été de dire voilà on est désolé il y a
eu un risque majeur et reporté d'une
semaine ça aurait été grave de dire aux
gens il y a un vrai problème et de et
parce que franchement à votre place moi
je vous dis franchement je sais pas si
vous arrêtez sur scène
je pense qu'il y a eu plusieurs
paramètres qu'ils ont pris en compte il
y avait des centaines de policiers tout
autour alors il faut savoir que toute la
salle a été fouillée par des chiens
spécialisés en explosifs
donc même dans notre loge ils ont ouvert
toutes nos valises ils ont ouvert tous
nos vêtements fouiller donc normalement
le risque était très très fortement
limité
ils l'ont arrêté à 17h30 nous on a été
évacué beaucoup plus tard donc il a
parlé entre entre le moment où il y a eu
la faux et la fouille de la salle et le
moment il s'est fait arrêter il a parlé
et puis vous le savez la télévision ça
coûte cher une cérémonie comme ça
et donc voilà un moment danger pour
manger pour le moment et donc les miss
elles ont été mises au courant avant la
cérémonie est-ce qu'il y en a qui ont
paniqué est-ce qu'elles ont été
déstabilisés moi je tiens juste à dire
une chose je suis hyper impressionné de
ces gonzesses quoi elles ont fait le
travail je ne sais candidate candidate
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé deux jours avec elle on a on
a répété elles ont fait un travail
incroyable et alors le comité à isolé
ses filles elle n'avait pas leur
téléphone avec elle déjà parce que les
quelques jours
donc ça s'est passé dans un parc
d'attraction donc cette salle le théâtre
il se trouve dans un parc d'attraction
donc on a pu les mettre ailleurs en
sécurité elle n'avait pas de tir par
exemple voilà par exemple
[Rires]
et aujourd'hui tu vas à chaque fois que
tu vas refaire un direct
parce que finalement en fait finalement
on est sain et sauf qu'il faut vraiment
retenir je crois que moi j'ai eu j'ai eu
des émotions voilà parce que parce qu'il
y a le contexte etc heureusement la
police a bien fait son travail les
autorités ont bien fait leur travail et
donc je vais essayer de zapper ça ça
s'est pas passé et on va passer à autre
chose et comme je dis toujours ben la
fête elle continue et on continue à
faire le boulot et puis et puis voilà il
faut passer à autre chose mais on a
pensé effectivement et à ce qui s'est
passé je ne compare pas le Bataclan j'ai
juste eu les images ça il faut que ce
soit clair les images de ce qui s'est
passé j'ai vu des documentaires par
centaines et donc c'est la première
chose à laquelle on pense et donc voilà